This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目“2%”中，我将剖析我们这个光怪陆离的现代社会中关于精神坚韧、体能和培养韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO. percent”。在Look Back at it播客节目中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在IHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听look back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人克尔·盖姆斯主持的《以艰难的方式学习》。这个空间关注的是黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套或多或少能称之为盔甲的东西。这向世界发出了一个信号，表明你是不好惹的。而且仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《以艰难的方式学习》。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于承担了后果。在Iheart广播应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。大家好。
Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, or listeners, wherever you are in the world, you know the deal. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, down the psychology of our 20s, dealing with our mental health, our mindset in our 20s or at any age can feel like an extremely uphill battle. And a lot of us are definitely looking for a solution. We're looking for some magical cure, some way out, a better way to cope with our everyday experience. So when we hear about something is seemingly life-changing as psychedelic treatment for our mental
欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，或者老听众，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落，你们都懂的。非常高兴能迎来你们的回归，收看我们的又一期节目，当然，我们要探讨我们20多岁的心理学，处理我们的心理健康，我们在20多岁或任何年龄段的心态，感觉就像是一场极其艰难的上坡战。而且我们中的许多人绝对都在寻找解决方案。我们在寻找某种神奇的解药，某种出路，一种能更好地应对我们日常体验的方法。所以当我们听到关于对我们的精神有如此看似改变人生的事物时
health, I think a lot of our ears immediately perk up. You know, these drugs that for such a long time have been really associated with like a party stoner lifestyle, like they're suddenly being talked about a lot in the healthcare community and this scene is very, very promising. Even though the FDA did recently reject the use of MDMA therapy to treat PTSD as we are recording this, it does seem like in general, across the world, like the tide is really turning. and I think we have a lot of questions. What does this actually entail? What would it feel like?
健康，我想我们许多人的耳朵立刻就竖起来了。你知道，这些长期以来真正与派对瘾君子生活方式联系在一起的药物，就像它们突然在医疗保健界被大量讨论一样，这个场景非常非常有希望。尽管正如我们录制时那样，美国食品药品监督管理局最近确实拒绝了使用MDMA疗法来治疗创伤后应激障碍，但看起来总的来说，在世界各地，风向确实在转变。而且我认为我们有很多问题。这到底需要什么？那会是什么感觉？
Could this, you know, one day be as common as treatment as antidepressants? And it's such an evolving space, personally one that I'm so fascinated by, but I'm definitely not an expert in. So today I thought I would bring on someone who is someone who knows so much about this, more than me, more than the average person, more than most of us, for that matter. Paul Austin, the founder of Third Wave, welcome to the show. Thank you, Gemma. It's great to be here. I love the introduction. You touched on so many hot items when it comes
这难道有一天能变得像抗抑郁药治疗一样普遍吗？这是一个不断发展的领域，就我个人而言，我对此非常着迷，但我绝对不是专家。所以今天我想请来一位专家，一位对这方面了解很多的人，比我懂得多，比普通人懂得多，甚至比我们大多数人都懂得多。第三波的创始人保罗·奥斯汀，欢迎来到节目。谢谢你，杰玛。很高兴来到这里。我很喜欢这个介绍。你谈到了很多热门话题，当涉及到
mental health and psychedelics. And I'm so excited to be able to talk with your audience about this today. It's a topic that's become very popular these last five or 60 years and there's still a lot of unknowns about it. So I'm hopeful that we can clear up some of these misconceptions and provide a great contextual understanding of what these medicines can do. Paul, can you just tell us a little bit about yourself before we get into it? What's third wave? what's been your experience that has gotten to the point of being like basically an expert psychedelic coach? So I grew up in a very traditional family in the Midwest, Grand Rapids, Michigan. Church was the center point of my upbringing, not in a fundamentalist way, but in a sort of strict,
心理健康和迷幻剂。我很高兴今天能和你的听众一起讨论这个问题。这是一个在过去五六年里变得非常受欢迎的话题，关于它仍然有很多未知数。所以我希望我们能澄清其中一些误解，并对这些药物能做什么提供一个很好的背景理解。保罗，在我们深入探讨之前，能先给我们简单介绍一下你自己吗？什么是第三波？是什么样的经历让你达到了基本上成为一名专家级迷幻教练的程度？我在中西部一个非常传统的家庭长大，密歇根州大急流城。教堂是我成长的中心，不是以一种原教旨主义的方式，而是一种有点严格的方式，
you're going to church every Sunday. And this is what we do as a family. And so as part of that naturally, my parents were very anti-drug. They were very against, especially illegal drugs like, you know, weed and cocaine and heroin and psychedelics. And at the age of 16, my best friend in high school introduced me to cannabis. I started to experiment with cannabis a little bit until my parents found up. And they sat me down one Sunday after church. And my dad looked at me and said, you know, I haven't been this disappointed since my brother passed away in a car accident. years before that, before we had sat down before they found out that I had smoked cannabis. So clearly it was a monumental, impactful thing that their only son had decided to start
你每个星期天都要去教堂。这就是我们作为家庭所做的事情。因此，作为其中的一部分，很自然地，我的父母非常反毒品。他们非常反对，尤其是非法药物，比如，你知道的，大麻、可可因、海洛因和迷幻剂。在我16岁的时候，我在高中的最好朋友向我介绍了大麻。我开始尝试一点大麻，直到我的父母发现。在一个星期天做完礼拜后，他们让我坐下。我父亲看着我说，你知道吗，自从我弟弟几年前在一场车祸中去世以来，
to experiment with cannabis. Now, what I felt in that experience was I felt happy, I felt laughter, I felt like it was very curiosity-provoking. And I was starting to learn more and more about cannabis at that time. why was it illegal? Why was it prohibited? Was it as bad as we thought it was? And so that started to lead me down this path of what Carl Jung would say is called individuation, which is the path of becoming oneself, right? Where I was like, clearly this person who I'm becoming won't be accepted by my family. I'm going to have to just keep this part of myself closed off.
在那之前，在我们坐下来之前，在他们发现我吸过大麻之前。所以很明显，他们唯一的儿子决定开始尝试大麻，这是一件具有里程碑意义的、影响深远的事情。现在，我在那次经历中感受到的是，我感到快乐，我感到欢笑，我觉得这很能激发好奇心。当时我开始越来越多地了解大麻。为什么它是非法的？为什么要禁止它？它真的像我们想象的那么糟糕吗？因此，这开始引导我走上卡尔·容格所说的个体化道路，也就是成为自我的道路，对吧？当时我想，很明显我正在成为的这个人不会被我的家庭接受。我只能把自己的这一部分封闭起来。
And soon after that, when I was 19, that same friend who introduced me to cannabis, introduced me to psilocybin mushrooms. And at the age of 19, I had my first experience with psilocybin mushrooms. Soon after that, I started to experiment with LSD a little bit as well. And whereas cannabis was like fun and I laughed a lot and helped me to get over some social anxiety, psychedelics are very profound. There were some really deep insights and awarenesses that I came to, one of which was, I'm not meant to live a conventional lifestyle.
在那之后不久，在我19岁的时候，那个把我领入大麻世界的同一个朋友，又把我引向了赛洛西宾蘑菇。在我19岁的时候，我有了第一次使用赛洛西宾蘑菇的经历。在那之后不久，我也开始稍微尝试一下LSD。大麻就像是好玩，我笑了很多，它帮我克服了一些社交焦虑，而迷幻剂则是非常深奥的。我得出了一些非常深刻的见解和认识，其中之一就是：我不是为了过一种常规的生活方式而生的。
That life is much more malleable than I previously had thought. I can create how I want to create. So why not do that? So soon after university, I moved abroad. I taught English in Turkey for a year. I became a digital nomad soon after that, worked and traveled everywhere. And at the age of 24, was in Budapest.
生活比我之前想象的要灵活得多。我可以创造我想要创造的东西。那为什么不这么做呢？所以在大学毕业后不久，我搬到了国外。我在土耳其教了一年英语。不久之后我成为了一名数字游民，到处工作和旅行。在24岁的时候，在布达佩斯。
This was 2015, almost 10 years ago. Notice that more and more people was starting to talk about psychedelics, Joe Rogan and Tim Ferriss and, you know, more clinical research was coming out about it. Cannabis was being re-evaluated and legalized, and I thought, I think this is going to become the next thing. So in 2015, I started third wave with the intention of making psychedelic education more accessible and more available to everyone. And so the idea of this third wave of psychedelics is that the first wave was the ancient and indigenous use of psychedelics, the second wave was the counterculture, the 50s and 60s. And then this third wave of psychedelics
那是2015年，差不多10年前。我注意到越来越多的人开始谈论迷幻剂，乔·罗根和蒂姆·费里斯，而且，你知道的，关于它的临床研究也越来越多。大麻正在被重新评估和合法化，我想，我认为这将会成为下一个大趋势。所以在2015年，我创立了第三波，其初衷是让迷幻教育更容易获得，并让每个人都能接触到。因此，关于迷幻剂第三波的这个想法是，第一波是古代和土著对迷幻剂的使用，第二波是反文化，即50年代和60年代。然后这第三波迷幻剂
is the modern sort of renaissance around psychedelic substances. And I believe it's critical that as part of this, we both honor the lineage and the indigenous wisdom of these medicines, and we also utilize best practices based on scientific frameworks and what we know about these psychedelics and how they interact with the body and the brain. So here I am talking about psychedelics, talking about microdosing, and it's been a pretty wild ride these last, you know, 10 years or so as they really started to come into prominent mainstream attention. Wow, I love that summary. And I really, really love what you said about combining the ancient indigenous wisdom with some of the more like, I don't know, I'd hate to say like Western,
是围绕迷幻物质的现代复兴。我相信至关重要的一点是，作为其中的一部分，我们既要尊重这些药物的谱系和本土智慧，也要利用基于科学框架的最佳实践，以及我们对这些迷幻剂的了解，以及它们如何与身体和大脑相互作用。所以现在我在这里谈论迷幻剂，谈论微剂量服用，在过去的十年左右里，这是一段相当疯狂的旅程，因为它们真正开始进入公众的主流视线。哇，我喜欢这个总结。而且我真的非常非常喜欢你所说的，将古老的土著智慧与一些更像是，我不知道，我讨厌说像是西方的，
but some of the more scientific, like quote-unquote scientific ways of seeing how this impacts our brain. And of course, I'm sure there have been so many populations who have been able to witness this since like the dawn of time. But a lot of their knowledge has been snuffed out through a lot of impacts through colonization, through just like a genuine disinterest in anything that was like counter to what a Western belief was. So I really like that we're acknowledging that because, I don't know, I just feel like there are so many things that we're returning to the roots of. I think about how there's been this huge biological reductionism of so much to do with mental health. And now people are like, hey, what if we, you know, just made sure that people had community? And what if we, like, went back to a sense of purpose?
但更具科学性，也就是所谓的科学方式结合起来，看看这如何影响我们的大脑。当然，我确信从开天辟地以来，有那么多的群体都能够见证这一点。但是他们的许多知识在殖民化的大量影响下被抹去了，仅仅是因为对任何与西方信仰相悖的事物真正的漠不关心。所以我真的很喜欢我们承认这一点，因为，我不知道，我只是觉得有太多事物我们正在回归其根源。我想到了精神健康领域的许多方面怎么会有这种巨大的生物学还原论。现在人们却说，嘿，如果我们，你知道的，只是确保人们拥有社群会怎么样？如果我们，比如，回归到一种使命感会怎么样？
And this feels very akin to that, like, very similar of returning to something that's been known for a long time. With your experience, what did you find that it kind of unlocked for you? I know you spoke quite generally about it, but did you see like a shift in how you saw the world, your attitudes towards the world, or just your own mental well-being? So one of the core things was this reconnection to spirit, we'll call it, or God or source or oneness. You know, I mentioned I had been raised in the church. It was a Protestant. So there's Catholic, there's Protestant, we were Protestant, and it was very dry. It was beautiful, but it was very dry.
这感觉非常类似于这一点，非常类似于回归一种早已为人所知的事物。根据你的经验，你发现它为你开启了什么？我知道你对此说得很笼统，但你有没有看到你对世界的看法、你对世界的态度，或者你自己的心理健康状况发生了转变？所以核心的事情之一是与精神的重新连接，我们称之为上帝、源头或合一。你知道的，我提到过我是在教堂长大的。那是一个新教。所以有天主教，有新教，我们是新教，而且非常枯燥。它很美，但非常枯燥。
We'd sing hymns, we'd say the prayers, we'd read the Bible verses, but it wasn't, I didn't really get it. I never really experienced God in its full entirety. And that's true, I think, of the majority of people who grow up in a religious environment. It's a lot of the rituals, it's a lot of the prayers, it's a lot of the hymns, but it's not a lot of the direct experience. And so I was becoming an atheist until I started to work with high doses of LSD and psilocybin mushrooms.
我们会唱赞美诗，我们会做祷告，我们会读圣经经文，但它不是，我并没有真正领悟它。我从未真正体验过上帝的全部完整性。我想，在宗教环境中长大的大多数人都是如此。这里有很多仪式，有很多祈祷，有很多赞美诗，但没有太多直接的体验。因此，我差点变成了一个无因论者，直到我开始使用高剂量的LSD和赛洛西宾蘑菇。
And when I had those experiences, all of a sudden, it helped to almost remind me of how connected I was to something greater than myself. It sort of reopened this concept of spirituality for me. And that had a number of downstream positive benefits, one of which was I recognize that I was deeply connected to everything around me. So the sort of classic cliche of LSD and psychedelics is hippies hugging trees, right? And yet anyone who's done a psychedelic in nature understands that because there is this deep love and connection to everything around us and how the indigenous peoples who worked with these substances, their interactions with it was because
当我有了这些体验后，突然之间，它几乎提醒了我，我是多么紧密地与某个比我自己更伟大的事物相连。它对我来说重新开启了灵性这一概念。这带来了一系列下游的积极益处，其中之一就是我认识到我与周围的一切都有着深刻的联系。所以LSD和迷幻剂的某种经典老套形象就是嬉皮士拥抱树木，对吧？然而，任何在大自然中体验过迷幻剂的人都明白这一点，因为对我们周围的一切以及那些使用这些物质的土著人民来说，存在着这种深沉的爱和连接，他们与之互动是因为
it helped them to remember that they were just these organisms. They were just these people that were part of nature, not above or better than nature. So I experienced that a deep and profound connection to the natural environment. I also experienced a sense of comfort with myself or authenticity of who I was and who I in. That when raised in a very religious environment, you are often shamed for who you are or guilted into behaving a certain way. And when I started to work with psychedelics, I came to realize, oh, I could just let go of a lot of that conditioning. At my core, at my essence, there's actually a deep sort of sense of innocence and love and purity. And I could tap back into that and remember that, which helped me, again, as cliche as it
这帮助他们记住，他们只是这些有机体。他们只是大自然一部分的人，而不是高于或优于大自然。所以我体验到了与自然环境的深刻而深远的连接。我还体验到了一种对自己的舒适感，或者对我自己是谁以及我身处何处的真实感。当你在一个非常宗教的环境中长大时，你常常会因为你是谁而感到羞耻，或者被内疚驱使着去做某种特定的行为。当我开始使用迷幻剂时，我开始意识到，哦，我可以放下很多这样的束缚。在我的核心，在我的本质中，其实有一种深沉的无辜感、爱和纯洁。我可以重新汲取并记住这一点，这再次帮助我，尽管听起来可能很老套，
may sound, to love myself again and love myself in a very deep way. And I think the outcome of that then was a lot of the depression and anxiety that I'd struggle with. When I started to work with psychedelics intentionally, they just helped me to commit to meditating more often, eating healthier, spending more time in nature, spending less time on screens, committing to practices and behaviors that ended up having a really positive and beneficial effect on my mental health. Because certainly when we take a psychedelic, that's doing some really interesting things to the brain that's great for some of these clinical conditions.
再次爱自己，并以一种非常深沉的方式爱自己。我想这带来的结果就是，我一直在与之抗争的很多抑郁和焦虑。当我开始有意地使用迷幻剂时，它们只是帮助我坚持更频繁地冥想，吃得更健康，花更多时间在大自然中，减少看屏幕的时间，坚持那些最终对我的心理健康产生真正积极和有益影响的练习和行为。因为当然，当我们服用迷幻剂时，那会对大脑做一些非常有趣的事情，这对其中一些临床病症很有好处，
but a lot of it is how are we changing our behaviors after the fact and who we hang out with and who we spend time with and psychedelics help that because they facilitate something called neuroplasticity. But it's not just the drug that's a magic pill. It really is a catalyst for change and we still have to commit to making those changes in our everyday life if we want to live better and feel better on an everyday basis. And that's the thing. If anyone ever offers you like a magic pill to cure every single problem in your life, walk away. Like that's, yeah, be highly, highly skeptical. And I think it's great that you're saying that about this as well, right?
但很大程度上在于我们在事后如何改变我们的行为，我们和谁在一起，我们和谁共度时光，而迷幻剂对此很有帮助，因为它们促进了一种叫做神经可塑性的东西。但这不仅仅是药物本身就是一颗神奇的药丸。它确实是改变的催化剂，如果我们想在日常生活中生活得更好、感觉更好，我们仍然必须致力于在日常生活中做出这些改变。这就是关键所在。如果有人曾经向你提供某种神奇的药丸来治愈你生活中的每一个问题，那就走开。这，是的，要保持高度、高度的怀疑态度。我认为你对这一点也这么说真是太棒了，对吧？
Like you can do, you can take anything, any substance under the sun, but if you don't do something with the experience and put that into practice afterwards, it's not going to work. I also really like what you said about experiencing a sense of oneness. And we had someone on just recently called Dr. Lisa Miller, who, who is a professor from Columbia who talks about spirituality and psychology. And I think a lot of us have, you know, who've experienced religion, the institution of religion over the years feel very like silenced by it, restricted by it, it feels very clinical. But there's this new wave of people who are like, actually having a sense of purpose,
就像你可以做任何事，服用阳光下的任何物质，但如果你不对这种经历做点什么并在事后付诸实践，它是不会起作用的。我也非常喜欢你所说的体验到合一体的感觉。我们最近邀请了一位名叫莉萨·米勒博士的嘉宾，她是哥伦比亚大学的一位教授，专门研究灵性和心理学。我想我们很多人，多年来经历过宗教、宗教体制的人，都觉得被它压制、被它限制，感觉非常临床。但新涌现出的一群人说，实际上拥有使命感，
feeling that there is something divine and bigger is incredibly psychologically nourishing. because the opposite of that is feeling like we are completely alone, all of us are alone, no one can understand our experience, that isolation is completely depressing. Like how does one not experience a level of like endogenous mental health experiences, if you really do believe that? But I want to move on to the impact on the brain and you talked about neuroplasticity, probably synaptic pruning comes into this. Before we get into that, actually, we need to clarify one thing,
感受到神圣和更宏大的事物的存在，在心理上是极其滋养的。因为与此相反的感觉是，觉得自己完全孤独，我们所有人都是孤独的，没有人能理解我们的经历，那种孤立感是彻底令人沮丧的。如果你真的那样认为，一个人怎么可能不经历某种程度的内源性心理健康体验呢？但我想要转向它对大脑的影响，你谈到了神经可塑性，突触剪枝可能也包含在其中。但在我们深入探讨之前，事实上，我们需要澄清一件事，
which we haven't clarified yet. Look, I'm getting ahead of myself. What does it mean when people say that psychedelics or medically supervised microdosing could be used to treat things like addiction or PTSD or end-of-life care? Like, what do they actually mean? We've talked someone about like a more recreational usage, shifting to like more of a medical environment or being used in like mainstream care. Is someone literally going to give you a tab of acid and say, off you go, like go and walk around?
我们还没澄清呢。看，我有点操之过急了。当人们说迷幻剂或医疗监督下的微剂量可以用来治疗成瘾、创伤后应激障碍或临终关怀等问题时，这是什么意思？他们到底是什么意思？我们已经谈到了一些更具娱乐性的用法，转变为更具医疗环境的用法，或者在主流护理中使用。是不是真的有人会给你一片迷酸，然后说，走吧，去到处走走？
So in the 1950s, when LSD first came on, the scene. It was invented in 1938. Psychedelic properties were discovered in 1943. It was used for about the first 15 to 20 years within strictly clinical environments to see what impact it would have on addiction, anxiety, depression. Like I said, over a thousand clinical papers were published on the efficacy of LSD Detroit, a range of conditions. And unfortunately, when it got out into the mainstream culture and was associated with Timothy Leary and turn on tune and drop out. The government prohibited and shut down not only the recreational use, but also the clinical research. And that wasn't resuscitated until the late 90s when Johns Hopkins
所以在20世纪50年代，当LSD首次出现时。它于1938年被发明。它的迷幻特性于1943年被发现。在最初的15到20年里，它被严格应用于临床环境，以观察它对成瘾、焦虑、抑郁的影响。正如我所说，关于LSD治疗一系列病症的功效，发表了超过一千篇临床论文。不幸的是，当它进入主流文化，并与蒂莫西·利里以及“加入、调整、脱离”联系在一起时。政府不仅禁止和关闭了娱乐性使用，还关闭了临床研究。直到90年代末，约翰霍普金斯大学开始研究这种关系时，这种情况才得以复苏
started to study this relationship between psilocybin and what they called mystical type experiences or, you know, experiencing God. And what they found in that early clinical research is that the more profound of an experience, a spiritual experience an individual had, the more likely it was to heal their depression or heal their addiction or heal, you know, OCD or some of these other clinical indications that they were struggling with. So on the one hand, it could be described at a spiritual level that when we experience the profundity of psychedelics, we are connected to the source of unconditional love. And when we feel in our every sort of part of our body that, that experience of unconditional love, it has these incredible impacts in our capacity to love,
开始研究赛洛西宾与他们所谓的神秘类型体验或，你知道的，体验上帝之间的关系。他们在早期临床研究中发现的是，一个人获得的灵性体验越深远，它就越能治愈他们的抑郁症，或者治愈他们的成瘾症，或者治愈，你知道的，强迫症或他们一直在与之抗争的其他一些临床适应症。所以一方面，可以说在精神层面上，当我们体验到迷幻剂的深奥时，我们就与无条件爱的源泉连接在了一切。当我们在身体的每一个部位都能感受到这种无条件爱的体验时，它对我们爱的能力产生了难以置信的影响，
our capacity to be with ourselves, to understand ourselves, and again, most importantly, to start to make changes in our everyday life that really honor and acknowledge that sense of self-love. Now, if we look at it from a neuroscientific lens, the common thread between depression, anxiety, addiction, OCD, even PTSD, is that when you do brain scans with people who struggle with these clinical conditions, the two hemispheres of the brain are not actively communicating, right? So the brain activity is sort of withering away. And when you take a psychedelic, it's like, you know, putting fertilizer into your brain. All of a sudden, it activates both hemispheres, neuronal connectivity gets turned back online, they start to communicate across the
我们陪伴自己、理解自己的能力，而且再次也是最重要的是，开始在日常生活中做出真正尊重和承认这种自爱感的改变。现在，如果我们从神经科学的镜头来看，抑郁症、焦虑症、成瘾症、强迫症甚至是创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）之间的共同主线是，当你对与这些临床病症作斗争的人进行脑部扫描时，大脑的两个半球没有积极地交流，对吧？所以大脑活动有点在萎缩。而当你服用迷幻剂时，就像，你知道的，给你的大脑施肥。突然之间，它激活了两个半球，神经元连接重新上线，它们开始跨半球进行交流。
hemispheres again, and that activation allows for a loosening of these constricted ways of being. So one of the technical terms is called the default mode network. And the default mode network is a network in our brain that helps us to do our everyday patterning. It's sort of habitual part of our brain that is on autopilot that allows us to navigate our everyday existence. When that becomes too rigid, when that becomes too constricted, then people start to notice that they're struggling with depression or addiction or anxiety. And so part of interrupting those patterns or interrupting those ruts is introducing a psychedelic. And so the psychedelic comes in and it creates a more entropic system. So more chaos.
大脑半球再次恢复活力，这种激活允许打破这些受限制的生存方式。因此，其中一个专业术语叫做默认模式网络。默认模式网络是我们大脑中帮助我们进行日常模式构建的网络。它是我们大脑中处于自动驾驶状态的习惯性部分，使我们能够驾驭日常生存。当这种默认模式变得过于僵化，变得过于受限时，人们就会开始注意到自己正在与抑郁症、成瘾症或焦虑症作斗争。因此，打破这些模式或打破这些陈规的一部分就是引入迷幻剂。因此，迷幻剂介入并创造了一个更高熵的系统。也就是更多的混乱。
so to say, and that chaos allows for a new perspective, a new look at things, which allows people to sort of get out of the pattern that they feel they've been stuck in and actually see that they can experience life in a new and unique way, that they don't have to feel that way all the time, that they can actually feel this other way. And then so much of working with a psychedelic when it comes to working with a therapist in particular, like in medical supervision, is it's not only the drug experience, but also how that coach or how that therapist or psychiatrist is supporting you after that drug experience. Because when you take a psychedelic, when the brain becomes more entropic, then it's opening something called a critical learning period. And the critical learning
可以这么说，这种混乱带来了一种新的视角，对事物有了新的看法，这使得人们能够摆脱他们觉得一直被困住的模式，并实际看到他们可以用一种新的独特的方式体验生活，他们不必一直都有这种感觉，他们实际上可以有这种别样的感觉。然后，在使用迷幻剂的过程中，特别是当与治疗师合作时，在医疗监督下，不仅仅是药物体验，还有教练或治疗师或精神病学家在药物体验后如何支持你。因为当你服用迷幻剂时，当大脑变得更有熵时，它就会开启一个叫做关键学习期的东西。而关键学习
period is like when you're four or five or six, your brain is in development. It's a sponge. It's soaking up all of these, you know, language and patterns and social behaviors and music, it can just soak it all up. And then as we get older, that learning period dies away, which is why they used to think, okay, when I'm, by time you're 26, you know, you can't teach an old dog new tricks. And now what we're discovering about psychedelics is it actually reopens that critical learning period for at least three to four weeks after the high-dose experience. And so people have this experience. They're able to see out of their depression or out of their addiction. And then the therapist or the coach is supporting them in that month after to start
期就像当你四岁、五岁或六岁时，你的大脑正在发育。它就像一块海绵。它在吸收所有这些，你知道的，语言、模式、社会行为和音乐，它能把这一切都吸收进去。然后随着我们变老，那个学习期就消失了，这就是为什么他们过去认为，好吧，等到你，当你到了26岁时，你知道的，你无法教老狗新把戏。而现在我们对迷幻剂的发现是，它实际上重新开启了高剂量体验后至少三到四周的关键学习期。所以人们有了这种体验。他们能够看到自己的抑郁或成瘾之外的东西。然后治疗师或教练在接下来的一个月里支持他们开始
to integrate what are actually new patterns of behavior you can start to implement that will help you feel this way more often. How do you have a more regulated nervous system? How do you not eat, you know, fast food or processed food? How do you get more sunlight and exercise? How do you spend more time with loved ones or cut out a toxic relationship, right? Like the psychedelic can help us to go, aha, but the therapeutic work, the coaching work actually allows those ahas to be integrated and become tangible in our everyday life. And you can totally see how that would also be remarkable for PTSD, right? You have all this trauma that's wired your brain one way. And I'm sure like another thing that comes up is like long-term potentiation, right? Neurons that
整合你可以开始实施的新行为模式，这将帮助你更频繁地感受到这种感觉。如何拥有一个更有调节能力的神经系统？如何不吃，你知道的，快餐或加工食品？如何获得更多的阳光和锻炼？如何花更多时间与亲人在一起或切断一段有毒的关系，对吧？迷幻剂可以帮助我们发出“啊哈”的感叹，但治疗工作、教练工作实际上允许这些“啊哈”被整合并在我们的日常生活中变得切实可行。你完全可以看出这对于PTSD（创伤后应激障碍）来说也是了不起的，对吧？你拥有所有这些将你的大脑塑造成某种特定方式的创伤。而且我确信，另一件浮现的事情是长期增强作用，对吧？神经元
that fire together, wire together. You've got all these major highways in your brain that have been paved in concrete that say, this is scary, this is trouble, I should be fearful, I should be worried based on these previous experiences. And it sounds like when you introduce a psychedelic, it's kind of like a tornado comes through, it might seem kind of scary. But with that opportunity, you can say, actually, no, like, that road doesn't really fit here anymore. That road, like, isn't really leading me to places where I want to go, like the roads being the neural highways and your brain. And so it allows for that neuroplasticity, as you said. And another really fascinating point that you brought up that I absolutely love that you said is this misconception that our brains
一起激发，一起连线。你的大脑中所有这些主要的高速公路都铺上了水泥，上面写着：这很可怕，这是麻烦，我应该感到恐惧，我应该根据这些过去的经验感到担忧。听起来，当你引入迷幻剂时，它有点像龙卷风过境，这可能看起来有点吓人。但有了这个机会，你可以说，事实上，不，那条路不再适合这里了。那条路，比如，并没有真正把我引向我想去的地方，这里的路指的是你大脑中的神经高速公路。因此，正如你所说，它允许了这种神经可塑性。你提出的另一个真正引人入胜的观点，我绝对喜欢你说的是这种误解，即我们的大脑
are fully developed, were done by the time what, 25, 26, 27 for men, 25 around for women. And that is just being, and I know that I've said that on the show before, I've been like, yeah, you know, your brain only gets fully developed at 25. It's a lot. It's a lot. absolutely not. Yes, like you have this frontal, like your frontal lobe basically like locks into place. But within your brain, there's so much opportunity for flexibility. It's why as people get older, their personality changes. It's why we see a decline actually in the experience of mental health as people get older as well, like past their 50s and 60s. So the brain is constantly evolving. have there been any
是完全发育成熟的，男性大概在什么时间完成，25、26、27岁左右，女性在25岁左右。这只是，我知道我以前在节目中说过，我曾说过，是的，你知道的，你的大脑到25岁才完全发育成熟。这很多。这很多。绝对不是。是的，就像你有这个额叶，基本上你的额叶就像是锁定在那个位置了。但在你的大脑内部，有如此多的灵活性空间。这就是为什么随着人们变老，他们的性格会发生改变。这也是为什么我们看到人们变老后，心理健康状况实际上有所下降，比如过了50岁和60岁以后。所以大脑一直在不断进化。有没有进行过任何
longitudinal or like in-depth studies on introducing psychedelics to a population group or to like a group of participants in seeing what what's happened? Like is there a study you can pull out that is like
纵向的或深入的研究，关于向人口群体或一组参与者引入迷幻剂并观察发生了什么？比如有没有你可以拿出来的一项研究，它是
a pretty important one that says this has changed people's lives or this has had this impact? So yes. I mean kind of a few notes here to highlight. In the 2010, 2011, maybe 2012,
相当重要的一个，表明这改变了人们的生活或产生了这种影响？所以是的。这里我想强调几点。在2010年、2011年，也许是2012年，
there was a research paper published that was a longitudinal research paper that essentially had asked people who had been using psychedelics for 40 or 50 years since the 1960s. Are you healthy? Are you okay? Because a lot of the sort of mainstream stigma was all these psychedelic users are, you know, dropping out or becoming schizophrenic or losing their mind. And what they found was when you look at it over a long time frame,
有一篇发表的研究论文，这是一篇纵向研究论文，基本上询问了自20世纪60年代以来已经使用迷幻剂40或50年的人们。你们健康吗？你们还好吗？因为主流污名中的很大一部分是，所有这些迷幻剂使用者都在，你知道的，退学、精神分裂或失去理智。他们发现的是，当你从长远的时间框架来看待它时，
psychedelics are really well tolerated by the majority of people in a population, that you do have, you know, the 1% who are schizophrenic or have potentially a personality disorder that should not be working with psychedelics, but that the broad population can tolerate psychedelics really, really quite easily and quite well. Now, in the last 20 years, there's been quite a few clinical research papers published on the efficacy of psychedelics. There's probably, I would say, three to emphasize. One is the research on MDMA for PTSD. So you mentioned PTSD already. When we have an acute trauma, it can often become stored in our body and our brain. And that trauma, that emotional imprint, will lead to a lot of nasty side effects over the long
绝大多数人在人口中对迷幻剂耐受良好，你确实有，你知道的，那1%精神分裂或可能有不应该使用迷幻剂的人格障碍的人，但普通大众可以非常、非常轻松且非常好地耐受迷幻剂。现在，在过去的20年里，已经发表了相当多的关于迷幻剂功效的临床研究论文。我可以说，大概有三篇需要强调。一篇是关于MDMA治疗PTSD的研究。所以你已经提到了PTSD。当我们遭受急性创伤时，它经常会储存在我们的身体和大脑中。这种创伤，那种情感印记，会在长期内导致许多讨厌的副作用。
term. When you work with something like MDMA, it creates a space of safety for the nervous system and for the brain to heal that underlying trauma. So that trauma can be open. opened up. It can be processed. It can be integrated. And it's no longer this festering wound that's in the subconscious of the psyche. It actually gets brought up and out. And it can be healed and properly worked with. And this nonprofit group Maps, which has a for-profit arm called Lycos, they were the ones who attempted to get MDMA approval. They did phase three clinical trials. So it was done over 12 weeks. They had therapists that were there with them. They did MDMA three times over those 12 weeks. 70% of those participants healed their PTSD,
当你使用像MDMA这样的物质时，它为神经系统和大脑创造了一个安全的空间来治愈潜在的创伤。这样创伤就可以被打开。它可以被处理。它可以被整合。它不再是潜意识中心里那个正在溃烂的伤口。它实际上被带了上来并释放出来。它可以得到治愈并妥善处理。这个名为Maps的非营利组织拥有一个名为Lycos的营利部门，他们是试图获得MDMA批准的人。他们进行了第三阶段临床试验。所以这是在12周内完成的。他们在那里有治疗师陪伴。他们在12周内服用了三次MDMA。70%的参与者治愈了他们的PTSD，
and they had PTSD on average for 17 years, which is... Wow. It's a huge number. 17 years. 17 years, 70%. So that's one really fascinating clinical trial. Another really fascinating clinical trial is this distinction between how psychedelics work on the brain and SSRIs work in the brain because a lot of people who are coming into psychedelic work have been on SSRIs or are currently on. We'll just quickly say SSRIs, but basically antidepressants. Yeah, that's helpful to clarify. So, and I'll provide a caveat here.
而且他们患PTSD平均有17年之久，也就是……哇。这是一个巨大的数字。17年。17年，70%。所以这是一项非常迷人的临床试验。另一项非常迷人的临床试验是，迷幻剂在大脑中的作用方式与SSRIs在大脑中的作用方式之间的区别，因为许多开始接触迷幻剂工作的人一直在使用SSRIs或者目前正在使用。我们很快会说SSRIs，但基本上就是抗抑郁药。是的，澄清这一点很有帮助。所以，我在这里提个警告。
If someone is listening to this who is on one of these medications and they're interested in getting off, make sure you do so under the guidance of a medical professional. and there's a substance called ketamine, which we can talk more about, which is legally and medically available and can be safely taken with a lot of these SSRIs under the guidance of a trained medical professional. And there are a lot of psychiatrists and other clinicians who are currently practicing this, but typically if folks ask, I say, look at ketamine, it's legal, it's available, it's been cleared by the FDA and check that out. But the research paper that I'm referring to compared the mechanism of action of psychedelics versus lexapro,
如果有人在听这个节目，正在服用其中一种药物，并且有兴趣停药，请确保在医疗专业人员的指导下这样做。有一种叫做氯胺酮的物质，我们可以多聊聊，它是合法且在医疗上可用的，并且在训练有素的医疗专业人员的指导下，可以安全地与许多这些SSRIs一起服用。目前有很多精神病学家和其他临床医生正在实践这一点，但通常如果人们询问，我会说，看看氯胺酮，它是合法的，可用的，已经获得了FDA的批准，去了解一下。但我所指的研究论文比较了迷幻剂与右旋西酞普兰的作用机制，
Zoloft, and these other SSRIs. And the big difference was the typical classic SSRIs are almost like a band-aid. They numb the person. So if your typical range of emotion, you know, is one to 10, an SSRI is going to make it three to six. So the lows aren't going to be as low, but you're not going to have the same level of highs either. It essentially numbs you and creates this sort of band-aid so you can sort of float, but it doesn't necessarily get to the wound that's underneath the core thing, whereas with psychedelics, they tend to open up the psyche. They tend to almost force a catharsis where the underlying trauma that may be causing the depression or the addiction, which is in most cases adverse childhood experience.
左洛复和这些其他的SSRIs。最大的区别在于，典型的经典SSRIs几乎就像创可贴。它们使人麻木。所以如果你典型的情绪范围，你知道的，是一到十，SSRIs会把它变成三到六。所以低谷不会那么低，但你也不会拥有同样水平的高潮。它本质上使你麻木，并创造了某种创可贴，这样你就可以漂浮，但它不一定能触及核心事物之下的伤口，而迷幻剂往往会打开心灵。它们往往几乎会强迫一种宣泄，即可能导致抑郁症或成瘾症的潜在创伤，在大多数情况下是不良童年经历，
experiences, which for your listeners, the ACE score was developed in the 90s. It was clinically proven that children who had these adverse childhood experiences were much more likely to be alcoholics or have addictions or be depressed. And so a lot of the new context around mental health is it has a lot to do with trauma. It's not just serotonin. It's not just biology. It's actually the psyche and how it's been treated. And so when we work with the psychedelic, it opens that up. And that trauma can start to be healed. That wound that's been festering underneath can start to be released and we can look at it
经历，对于你的听众来说，ACE（不良童年经历）评分是在90年代开发的。临床证明，有这些不良童年经历的儿童更有可能成为酗酒者、有成瘾问题或抑郁症。因此，关于心理健康的大部分新背景是，它与创伤有很大关系。它不仅仅是血清素。它不仅仅是生物学。它实际上是心灵以及它是如何被对待的。因此，当我们与迷幻剂合作时，它会打开这一点。那个创伤可以开始被治愈。那个一直在底下溃烂的伤口可以开始被释放，我们可以审视它，
and it can be integrated as well. So that's another really interesting research trial. So the three that I mentioned are longitudinal data from the 60s that psychedelics are really well tolerated across thousands of people that have been studied. the clinical trial showing how effective MDMA is at treating PTSD, 70% remission rate with participants who on average have PTSD for 17 years, and then showing specifically how are psychedelics different than necessary? Well, Lexa Prozoloff, Prozac, numb us, whereas psychedelics actually make us more enlivened and they allow us to get to the core thing that's underneath the trauma so it doesn't continue to persist over the long term. I really love that explanation. And I love that you said, you know, SSRIs. They have their time and a place and I think it's really difficult because you will go to a doctor and that is the first thing that they will prescribe you.
并且它也可以被整合。所以这是另一项非常有趣的临床试验。我提到的三项是：60年代以来的纵向数据表明，迷幻剂在被研究的数千人中耐受性非常好；临床试验显示MDMA治疗PTSD有多有效，患有PTSD平均达17年的参与者缓解率达到了70%；然后具体展示了迷幻剂与SSRIs有何不同？嗯，Lexapro、Zoloft、Prozac让我们麻木，而迷幻剂实际上让我们更有活力，它们使我们能够触及创伤之下的核心事物，这样它就不会在长期内持续存在。我真的很喜欢这个解释。我也喜欢你说，你知道的，SSRIs。它们有其时间和地点，我认为这真的很难，因为你会去看医生，而那是他们开给你的第一种药。
And of course you're going to trust your doctor as you should, you know, but I think it's also we've gotten to a point where that has been the major way of treating things for a long time and yet. and I'm saying this is someone who has been on SSRIs before and, you know, we've been doing it for a long time and yet rates of mental health are increasing. So if you can imagine, like, people being like, oh, we have this cure for cancer. We have this, you know, treatment for cancer and they're giving it to every cancer patient and yet no one's getting better. Like, you do have to start asking questions. Also, with the adverse childhood experiences score, really worth looking into because there was a recent. study on this and it's really interesting because I actually helped with this study. It was done in Australia. It's called the child maltreatment study. And you might think like childhood trauma is
当然你会信任你的医生，你也应该这样，你知道的，但我认为我们也到了这样一个地步，即那是长期以来治疗问题的主要方式，然而。而且我是作为一个曾经服用过SSRIs的人来说这番话的，你知道的，我们已经这样做了很长时间，然而心理健康的发病率却在上升。所以你可以想象，就像，人们说，哦，我们有这个治疗癌症的良药。我们有这个，你知道的，治疗癌症的方法，并且他们把它给每一个癌症患者，然而没有人好转。所以，你确实必须开始提出问题。此外，关于不良童年经历评分，真的很值得一看，因为最近有一项。关于这方面的研究，非常有趣，因为我实际上参与了这项研究。它是在澳大利亚完成的。它被称为儿童虐待研究。你可能会认为童年创伤就像是
neglect, abuse from parents. It can also be sibling abuse. It can also be bullying. It can also be experiencing the death of a parent, a natural disaster, a family trauma, financial insecurity. So a lot of people might think, well, you know, nothing really that bad happened to me when I was a child. And then you dig into it and you can be like, yeah, but there's also, you know, the system that you grew up in may not have actually been able to support you. It's not all about individual events. It's also about a culture or society that may have been emotionally neglectful. But we're going to take a short break because I'm getting, I'm letting time get ahead of me here. I'm so fascinated by this conversation, Paul.
来自父母的忽视、虐待。也可能是兄弟姐妹间的虐待。也可能是霸凌。还可能是经历父母离世、自然灾害、家庭创伤、经济不稳定。所以很多人可能会想，嗯，你知道的，我小时候其实没发生什么特别糟糕的事。然后当你深入探讨时，你就会发现，是的，但是还有，你知道的，你长大的那个系统可能实际上并没有能力支持你。这并不完全关乎个别事件。这也关乎一种可能在情感上有所忽视的文化或社会。但我们要稍微休息一下，因为我有点，我在这里让时间过得太快了。我对这个对话太着迷了，保罗。
So we're going to take a short break, and when we come back, I want to talk about some of the important ethical standards that we should be considering when it's not entirely helpful to be using psychedelics and also what the future of this treatment might look like. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience. in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience
所以我们要休息一会儿，当我们回来时，我想谈谈一些重要的伦理标准，当使用迷幻药并非完全有帮助时，我们应该考虑这些标准，以及这种治疗的未来可能会是什么样子。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学，
that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side
它们主导着健康产业。我们曾坚信种子油本质上会导致发炎。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即I-Heart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWO%”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上拍了两次小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马尔科姆·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备在那天聊聊可卡因，只是想让大家知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我的意思是，马尔科姆，此时此刻，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集。所以我开始看出这其中有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan, Ryan, Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听look back at it。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安、瑞安，有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要。你成为一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。这也是两个不同的信任层面。我希望你能真正地成为一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle, to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改过这个特定的测试，对吗，某人？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大队来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marangini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉格尼尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. All right, so we're back with Paul Austin, the founder of Third Wave. Paul, we have talked a lot about how this is like. like so magical. This treatment just sounds absolutely wonderful. And there is just so much evidence to prove it. So much research being done currently. But we can't talk about this and I know
随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在正义在亚利桑那州得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听Love Trapped播客。好的，我们欢迎第三波（Third Wave）的创始人保罗·奥斯汀回归。保罗，我们之前聊了很多关于这感觉就像是。如此神奇。这种治疗听起来绝对棒极了。而且有这么多的证据来证明它。目前正在进行这么多的研究。但我们不能不谈这个，而且我知道
people are going to be like, well, what about schizophrenia? What about if I have a really disruptive and distressing experience? So what are some of the important kind of ethical standards that we need to think about as this practice is rapidly growing, both in a personal usage way, but also in like a medical usage way. So what I often say is that the most dangerous aspect of psychedelic work is the fact that these are still illegal almost everywhere. We have seen some momentum over the last few years. The state of Oregon has legalized psilocybin mushrooms,
人们会问，嗯，那精神分裂症呢？如果我有非常具有破坏性和痛苦的经历怎么办？因此，随着这项实践的飞速发展，无论是在个人使用方面，还是在医疗使用方面，我们需要考虑哪些重要的人类伦理标准？所以我经常说，迷幻药工作中最危险的方面是这样一个事实：它们在几乎所有地方仍然是非法的。在过去的几年里，我们看到了一些势头。俄勒冈州已将裸盖菇素（俗称神奇蘑菇）合法化，
the state of Colorado has legalized all plant medicines, psychedelic plant medicines, Jamaica and the Netherlands have legalized psilocybin mushrooms. Australia even has rescheduled psilocybin and MDMA from Schedule 9 to Schedule 8, I believe. The TGA did that last year. So it's becoming more accessible and available, but these are still largely illegal substances.
科罗拉多州已将所有植物药、迷幻植物药合法化，牙买加和荷兰已将裸盖菇素合法化。澳大利亚甚至已将裸盖菇素和MDMA（摇头丸）从第九表（Schedule 9）调整到第八表（Schedule 8），我相信是的。TGA（澳大利亚药品管理局）去年就是这么做的。所以它变得越来越容易接触和获得，但这些在很大程度上仍然是非法物质。
And that is, in fact, the most dangerous part about psychedelics is that they are illegal. I would say the second aspect of this, and I mentioned this in the previous section about research and the longitudinal studies around psychedelics, is those who have a family history of schizophrenia or psychosis or personal history of schizophrenia or psychosis should not be taking psychedelics, even at a microdose, a very low level. Those who have a personality disorder should not be working with psychedelic. those who don't feel called to taking psychedelics should not be taking psychedelics, right? There does have to be this sort of willful choice that's involved if you want to do this work
而这，事实上，也是迷幻药最危险的部分，那就是它们是非法的。我想说第二点，我在上一节关于研究和关于迷幻药的纵向研究中提到过这一点，即有精神分裂症或精神病家族史的人，或者有精神分裂症或精神病个人史的人，不应该服用迷幻药，即使是微剂量，非常低的水平。有性格障碍的人不应该使用迷幻药。那些没有感受到想要服用迷幻药的召唤的人不应该服用迷幻药，对吧？如果你想做这项工作，确实需要有一种刻意的选择，
because doing a macro dose, a therapeutic dose of a psychedelic is not necessarily for the faint of heart. It can be very intense emotionally. It can be very difficult at times. There can be a lot of anger and grief and sadness and challenging emotions that come to the surface that need to be processed and held. And that's why it's so critical that when working with psychedelics, you pay attention to set and setting is the number one. Set or mindset is how you come into that experience
因为服用宏观剂量，即迷幻药的治疗剂量，并不一定适合胆小的人。它在情感上可能非常强烈。有时可能会非常困难。可能会有大量的愤怒、悲伤、哀恸和具有挑战性的情绪浮出水面，这些都需要被处理和包容。这就是为什么在使用迷幻药时，至关重要的是你要注意“心态和环境（Set and setting）”，这是第一位的。“心态（Set）”或思维方式是你进入这种体验的方式，
and setting is the physical environment that you're in. It's really critical to have a physical person who is present with you. That could be for some folks, a sitter or a friend who is just there to make sure you're safe. for those who are really looking at deep clinical issues that they're looking to heal and resolve, that most likely will be a therapist, a trained therapist. There's also other guides and shamans and coaches. In fact, through the psychedelic coaching institute, we train coaches, therapists, practitioners, and guides, and what I call the five key elements.
而“环境（Setting）”则是你所处的物理环境。有一个在场的真实人物是至关重要的。对于某些人来说，这可以是一个陪伴者或朋友，他就在那里以确保你是安全的。对于那些真正寻求深入治疗他们希望治愈和解决的临床问题的人来说，那很可能是一位治疗师，一位训练有素的治疗师。还有其他向导、萨满和教练。事实上，通过迷幻教练学院，我们培训教练、治疗师、从业者和向导，教授我所说的五个关键要素。
And I'll briefly describe those five key elements because I think these are essential to the ethical use of psychedelics. for those listening at home, that if you're working with a coach, a guide, a therapist, a practitioner, they should know how to assess you. So what is the assessment process like? They should know how to prepare you. How are they preparing you or what's preparation like for the experience? They should have a sense of how to facilitate the actual experience. You should be asking them questions about what medicine is appropriate. How much of that medicine? Where are we going to do it? What's the overall flow of the experience? Will there be music involved? Will there not be music involved, you know, just getting a sense of some of these questions for how the
我将简要描述这五个关键要素，因为我认为这些对于迷幻药的道德使用至关重要。对于在家收听的听众，如果你正在与教练、向导、治疗师、从业者合作，他们应该知道如何评估你。那么评估过程是怎样的？他们应该知道如何为你做准备。他们是如何为你准备的，或者体验前的准备工作是怎样的？他们应该对如何引导实际体验有所感觉。你应该向他们询问有关什么药物是合适的的问题。使用多少剂量的药物？我们要在哪里进行？体验的整体流程是怎样的？会涉及音乐吗？不会涉及音乐吗，你知道的，只是对这些关于体验将如何进行的
experience will go. Integration is key. So after we have that experience, will they support you on an ongoing basis to ensure that that experience can be woven in back to your everyday life? And then microdosing. I say that, you know, most practitioners should know how microdosing can support the integration process. And microdosing is a sub-intoxicating dose of a psychedelic. It's about one-tenth of a normal therapeutic dose that people might do two or three times per week for a period of time because it helps with mood, energy, sleep, and a number of other things. So the ethical use of psychedelics comes down to, I think, those five key elements, assessment, preparation, facilitation, integration, and microdosey.
问题有个大致的了解。整合是关键。所以，在我们有了这种体验之后，他们会为你提供持续的支持，以确保这种体验能够重新融入你的日常生活吗？然后是微剂量。我说，你知道的，大多数从业者应该知道微剂量如何支持整合过程。微剂量是迷幻药的一种亚致幻剂量。它大约是正常治疗剂量的十分之一，人们可能会在一段时间内每周服用两到三次，因为它有助于改善情绪、精力、睡眠以及许多其他事情。因此，我认为迷幻药的道德使用归结为这五个关键要素：评估、准备、引导、整合和微剂量。
Now, the final thing that I'll emphasize is because psychedelics are illegal, because they're prohibited, it can also be very difficult to get a sense of who can I work with, right? Because the other shadowy, sort of risky part about working with drugs that make you more suggestible, that alter your consciousness is there have been stories out there where people feel like boundaries have been crossed. You know, they feel like, you know, maybe they worked with a male shaman or facilitator and there wasn't consent for a sort of. type of touch as part of the experience. So I think the really big ethical consideration is make sure if you do this experience with an individual, you get references or you've had a trusted friend
现在，我要强调的最后一点是，因为迷幻药是非法的，因为它们是被禁的，也很难弄清楚我可以和谁合作，对吧？因为使用那些让你更容易被暗示、改变你意识的药物的另一个阴暗面、某种风险在于，曾有过一些故事，人们觉得界限被跨越了。你知道，他们觉得，也许他们和一个男性萨满或引导者合作，作为体验的一部分，并没有对某种类型的触摸达成共识。所以我认为一个非常重大的伦理考量是，如果你和某个人一起进行这种体验，确保你获得了推荐信，或者你有一位信任的朋友，
who has sat with them before or you know someone who can vet for them. Because unlike doctors and therapists and, you know, these people who are certified by boards, whether it's, you know, a national board or a state board, there's not a lot of mechanisms to report people who might be unethical in the psychedelic space. And so it's really critical that if you're interested in this, that you find a practitioner that is trustworthy, who you can work with. And thankfully, you know, on our website, Third Wave, we have a directory of practitioners. So we have retreat centers, clinics, coaches, and therapists that we've vetted, and that we recommend to our audience as folks that they can work with. Because I do think this is the biggest ethical risk is that people are not
他以前曾和他们一起体验过，或者你知道有人能为他们作担保。因为不像医生和治疗师，你知道的，这些由委员会认证的人，无论是国家委员会还是州委员会，在迷幻药领域，没有什么机制去举报那些可能缺乏道德的人。因此至关重要的是，如果你对此感兴趣，你要找到一个值得信赖、你可以合作的从业者。值得庆幸的是，你知道的，在我们的网站Third Wave上，我们有一个从业者名录。所以我们有我们已经审核过并推荐给我们的受众作为可以合作的人选的疗养中心、诊所、教练和治疗师。因为我确实认为这是最大的伦理风险，那就是人们并没有
waiting for the law to change to start to take psychedelics. In fact, last year in the United States, 8 million people took psilocybin mushroom in 2023 alone. That's 3.1% of the population. Four million of those people were microdosing, right? So interest is growing, but people who are working with this, if you're going to do a therapeutic dose, a high dose of a psychedelic, have a guide. have a sitter, have a therapist, have a coach, a practitioner, who you trust and can hold that space for you as you're navigating. That is such helpful advice. And it really does point to this huge problem, right? If this isn't legalized or if there is a progress towards making this a genuine therapeutic intervention, you do have these problems. And so we know that, you know,
等待法律改变才开始服用迷幻药。事实上，仅在2023年，美国就有800万人在一年内食用了裸盖菇素蘑菇。这占人口的3.1%。其中四百万人当时正在进行微剂量服用，对吧？因此，兴趣在增长，但那些正在使用它的人，如果你要进行治疗剂量、高剂量的迷幻药，请找一个向导。找一个陪伴者，找一个治疗师，找一个教练、从业者，一个你信任的人，能够在你在其中摸索时为你提供那个空间。这真是非常有用的建议。它确实指出了这个巨大的问题，对吧？如果这没有合法化，或者如果没有朝着使其成为真正医疗干预措施的进展，你就会遇到这些问题。所以我们知道，你知道的，
the current approach of like, don't do those things, just no, don't touch that. like don't do drugs, whatever. I sound so lame saying that. But that way of thinking about it that I think a lot of like government bodies want us to take on board is incredibly unhelpful because people are still going to do it, but they end up and can end up, not always, in pretty dangerous situations. I like that you pointed out. The fact that it is illegal means that there is no way to discern at times, like whether what you're consuming is something that you want to be consuming, you know, in Australia. we have problems with that with like NDMA and it being mixed with things that perhaps you don't want to consume. And I just think all of that is just more of an argument as to why this
当前的这种方法，比如“不要做那些事，就是别碰，别碰那个，别碰毒品，管他呢。”我说这话听起来太无力了。但我认为很多政府机构希望我们接受的那种思考方式是极其无济于事的，因为人们无论如何还是会去做，但他们最终往往会，而且可能会，并不总是，陷入相当危险的境地。我喜欢你指出的这一点。事实上，它是非法的，这意味着有时无法辨别你所消耗的东西是否是你想要消耗的东西，你知道，在澳大利亚，
should be more widely accepted by the medical community. Obviously that takes time with needing studies and approval. But until that does happen, you are going to see those instances that you briefly spoke about, which don't dominate the experience as well, of it being unsafe because people aren't bedded by, you know, you don't, imagine like if you had this approved course, like what it would take to become a psychologist
我们在MDMA等物质上遇到了这样的问题，它被掺入了也许你并不想消耗的东西。而我只是认为所有这些都更是为什么医学界应该更广泛地接受这一点的论据。显然这需要时间，需要研究和批准。但直到那发生之前，你将会看到你简短谈到的那些实例，它们虽然不主导整个体验，但由于它们不安全，因为人们没有经过审核，你知道的，想象一下，如果你有这样一个获得批准的课程，比如成为一名心理学家
or a surgeon, so people could know that they were going to an expert and it sounds like you're kind of doing some of that work before the traditional, like, medical community catches up. And that kind of brings me to a great question and probably one of my final questions. firstly what is holding us back is it just stigma and secondly if you could like envision a future
或外科医生所需要经历的，这样人们就能知道他们是在向专家求助，听起来你似乎在传统医学界赶上之前，已经在做其中一部分工作了。这让我想到了一个极好的问题，可能也是我最后的几个问题之一。首先，是什么在阻碍我们？仅仅是污名吗？其次，如果你能设想一个未来，
where this was part of our medical system like what would that look like what would you want that to look like so what's holding us back this is a great question and it's something I reflect on a lot I think at a very high level as a We have never had psychedelics available to us as a global culture. Another way to describe that is historically when psychedelics have been used, they've always been in the underground. They've always been in sort of specific indigenous groups and communities. In ancient Greece, they had these things called the Elyucinian mysteries that Plato, Aristotle, and Marcus Aurelius participated in. And they were the mysteries.
其中这成为了我们医疗系统的一部分，那会是什么样子？你希望它是什么样子？所以，是什么在阻碍我们？这是一个很好的问题，这也是我经常反思的事情。我认为，从一个非常高的层面来看，作为一种全球文化，我们从来没有让迷幻药供我们使用过。另一种描述方式是，历史上当迷幻药被使用时，它们总是在地下。它们总是存在于某些特定的本土群体和社群中。在古希腊，他们有被称为“厄琉西斯秘仪（Elyucinian mysteries）”的东西，柏拉图、亚里士多德和马可·奥勒留都曾参与其中。而这些就是秘仪。
You couldn't talk about them. If you talked about what happened in these experiences, you were either killed or excommunicated. That's how sacred they were. So there is this deep relationship between psychedelic use and sort of the underground, the mystery, the unknown. And so when we're starting to bring this above ground for mental health and for a lot of the current ills that people face in modern society, there's a big question about how to do that safely. because in the past it wasn't that everyone had access to doing five grams of mushrooms or drinking ayahuasca or significantly altering their consciousness.
你不能谈论它们。如果你谈论了在这些体验中发生了什么，你要么被处死，要么被逐出教会。它们就是如此神圣。因此，迷幻药的使用与某种地下状态、神秘、未知之间存在着这种深厚的联系。所以，当我们开始把这带到地面上来用于心理健康以及现代社会人们面临的许多现存弊病时，关于如何安全地做到这一点，存在着一个巨大的问号。因为在过去，并不是每个人都有机会服用5克蘑菇，或者饮用死藤水（Ayahuasca），或者显著改变他们的意识。
And the drugs that we are most familiar with, alcohol, nicotine, and caffeine are very different than a psychedelic experience. So I think the first thing to point to is instead of a stigma, I think it's more a lack of psychedelic literacy, that we are still learning, oh, ketamine is different than MDMA, and MDMA is different than psilocybin. And these psychedelic class of drugs are actually very different than cocaine and heroin and, you know, highly addictive substances. Because one thing I may have emphasized, but I'll reemphasize again, is psychedelics are anti-addicted. They actually help to heal addictions. They're not like these other illicit drugs, cocaine, heroin, methamphetamines, etc.,
我们最熟悉的药物——酒精、尼古丁和咖啡因，与迷幻体验有着很大的不同。所以我认为首先要指出的不是污名，我认为更多的是缺乏迷幻药素养，我们仍在学习，哦，氯胺酮（K粉）不同于MDMA，MDMA不同于裸盖菇素。而这一类迷幻药物实际上与可卡因、海洛因以及高度成瘾物质有很大不同。因为我要强调的一点，我可能已经强调过了，但我会再次强调，迷幻药是抗成瘾的。它们实际上有助于治疗成瘾。它们不像其他这些非法药物，可卡因、海洛因、甲基安非他命等，
that are very, very different drug class. So I think on the one hand, it's psychedelic literacy. I would say on the other hand, it's just the momentum that is required to develop policy and regulatory frameworks that work for people who want to do this legally. We've seen this in Oregon. Oregon has legalized psilocybin mushrooms. They now have a regulatory framework in place where you have to get licensed by the state as a service center or facilitator, the people who want to take the law.
那是截然不同的一类药物。所以一方面，我认为是迷幻药素养。另一方面，我可以说，是为了制定对想要合法进行这一操作的人适用的政策和监管框架所需的推动力。我们在俄勒冈州看到了这一点。俄勒冈州已经将裸盖菇素合法化。他们现在拥有了一个监管框架，你必须获得州政府的许可才能作为服务中心或引导者，那些想要服用法律允许的
psilocybin mushrooms have to go into these service centers to do it there. Colorado has a bit more of a flexible approach now, where it's not just psilocybin, but also ayahuasca and San Pedro. And there are various centers that can be licensed and it's quite open. So I think a lot of it is just, you know, we have a phrase in sort of startup world, which is you're building the airplane as you're bringing it down the runway. It's a little bit like that with psychedelics. It's this thing that's never been done before.
裸盖菇素蘑菇的人必须去这些服务中心在那里进行。科罗拉多州现在采取了一种稍微灵活一点的方法，不仅仅是裸盖菇素，还包括死藤水和圣佩德罗仙人掌（San Pedro）。并且有各种可以获得许可的中心，而且相当开放。所以我认为很多事情只是，你知道的，我们在初创企业界有一句话，那就是“你在跑道上滑行时正在组装飞机”。对迷幻药来说有点像这样。这是从未做过的事情。
We've never made them accessible and available to a wide populace. And that's why I firmly believe in the utility of microdosing. I do not believe that everyone is necessarily suited to do a high dose of a psychedelic. I think for a lot of people, it's too chaotic, it's too much, it's too overwork. It's too destabilizing. What I do believe is that the vast majority of people, when I say vast majority, I'm thinking 90% plus of people would benefit from microdosing with a psychedelic because it's sub-intoxicating. It's not changing your everyday perception.
我们从未让它们变得对广大民众易于接近和获得。这就是为什么我坚信微剂量的效用。我不认为每个人都必然适合做高剂量的迷幻药。我认为对于很多人来说，这太混乱了，太多了，太让人应接不暇了。太不稳定了。我确实相信绝大多数人——当我说是绝大多数人时，我指的是90%以上的人——都会受益于迷幻药的微剂量服用，因为它是亚致幻的。它不会改变你的日常感知。
It's shifting things enough, making your brain slightly neuroplastic, but it's not overwhelming it with new information. It's anti-addictive. unlike SSRIs, back to SSRIs, right, 50% of people who start taking SSRIs cannot get off of them because the withdrawal symptoms are so bad. With microdoses of psychedelics, with psychedelics generally, there's no withdrawal symptoms. So I feel like microdosing is the way of the future. And so part of what I'm most excited about is, you know, we have third wave as our educational brand and company. We have our psychedelic coaching institute, which trains practitioners. And a
它只是稍微改变了一些东西，让你的大脑略微具备神经可塑性，但它不会用新信息压垮大脑。它是抗成瘾的。与SSRIs（选择性5-羟色胺再摄取抑制剂）不同，回到SSRIs，对吧，50%开始服用SSRIs的人无法停药，因为戒断症状太严重了。而使用迷幻药微剂量，广义上的迷幻药，是没有戒断症状的。所以我觉得微剂量是未来的发展方向。因此，我最兴奋的事情之一是，你知道的，我们有第三波作为我们的教育品牌和公司。我们有我们的迷幻教练学院，它培训从业者。而且在
couple years ago, I also started a nonprofit called the microdosing collective, and we're focusing on how do we develop policy so people can access microdoses of psilocybin mushrooms in a safe and legal way. Because for anyone who's listening to this, who lives in New York, or you live in L.A. or you live in Austin, or you live, you know, in Sydney, mushrooms are everywhere now, right? Like the DEA is focusing a lot of their time, energy, and effort on fentanyl as they should, and cocaine and organized crime as they should. So there's this been this massive growth of interest in mushrooms and all of these chocolate bars and supplements and everything that's everywhere. And it's all illegal for the most part, except in Colorado.
几年前，我也创立了一个名为微剂量集体（the microdosing collective）的非营利组织，我们专注于如何制定政策，以便人们能够以安全合法的方式获取裸盖菇素蘑菇的微剂量。因为对于任何正在收听这个节目、住在纽约、洛杉矶、奥斯丁或者悉尼的人来说，蘑菇现在到处都是，对吧？就像缉毒局（DEA）把他们的大部分时间、精力和努力都集中在芬太尼上（他们本该如此），以及可卡因和有组织犯罪上（他们本该如此）。因此，对蘑菇以及到处都是的这些巧克力棒、补充剂和所有东西的兴趣出现了巨大增长。而且在很大程度上，除了科罗拉多州，它们都是非法的。
And it's not regulated. And so people end up getting this. They don't know what's in it. And so we feel like with the microdosing collective, people are going to do this anyway. We need to develop consumer protection. We need to have third-party tested supplements. And people need to be able to access this because as we were talking about before, Prozac is no better than placebo, right?
并且没有受到监管。所以人们最终买到了这些。他们不知道里面有什么。所以我们觉得通过微剂量集体，人们无论如何都会这样做。我们需要建立消费者保护机制。我们需要有第三方检测的补充剂。人们需要能够获得这些，因为正如我们之前所讨论的，百忧解（Prozac）并不比安慰剂好，对吧？
And a lot of people who get on Prozac and Lexapro can't get off. And there's all these nasty side effects. We need different treatments. We need treatments that actually work. And I do believe that psychedelics and microdosing in particular is a treatment modality that can transform our medical system, where the emphasis is much less on just take a pill to fix every ill. And the emphasis is much more on how can psychedelics and other tools like breathwork and yoga and meditation, other contemplated practices that facilitate neuroplasticity, how can those be
而且很多服用百忧解和来士普（Lexapro）的人无法停药。并且有所有这些令人讨厌的副作用。我们需要不同的治疗方法。我们需要真正起作用的治疗方法。我确实相信迷幻药，特别是微剂量，是一种可以改变我们医疗系统的治疗模式，在这种模式下，重点不再仅仅是“吃一颗药来治愈每一种疾病”。重点更多地转向了迷幻药和其他工具，如呼吸法、瑜伽和冥想，以及其他促进神经可塑性的正念练习，如何才能成为
catalysts to behavioral change. So we eat healthier. We sleep more. We exercise more. We practice gratitude. We spend more time outside. At the end of the day, drugs are drugs. They aren't the fix themselves.
行为改变的催化剂。所以我们吃得更健康。我们睡得更多。我们锻炼更多。我们练习感恩。我们在户外花更多的时间。归根结底，药物就是药物。它们本身并不是解药。
But psychedelics are catalysts. They're neurocatalytic so we can actually change our behaviors. And that makes me hopeful. It makes me hopeful that we'll move from having a sick care system to a real health care system and we'll start to focus not just on taking a pill for every ill, but actually taking responsibility for our health and well-being and making intentional choices to live in a more connected and loving way. What a beautiful way to finish. What a beautiful way to finish. I'm going to ask you one final question. I feel like that was just such a beautiful way to put
但迷幻药是催化剂。它们是神经催化剂，因此我们可以真正改变我们的行为。这让我充满希望。这让我充满希望，我们将从拥有一个疾病护理系统转变为一个真正的医疗保健系统，我们将开始不仅关注为每种疾病吃药，而且真正对我们的健康和福祉负责，并做出有意识的选择，以一种更有联系、更有爱心的方式生活。多么美丽的结束方式。多么美丽的结束方式。我要问你最后一个问题。我觉得这真是太美妙的方式来概括
exactly what we're talking about today. This is the question I ask every single. single guest. So you're coming on during like our 12 days of guest series obviously. And it's just like a chance to talk to like 12 people who just know this shit are really cool. Our experts have a new perspective. What would be your one, your biggest piece of advice for people in their 20s doesn't have to be related to what we talked about today, which is one thing you wish that someone had sat you down and told you. My biggest piece of advice for someone in their 20s is to pursue work to pursue a career, to pursue some form of profession that is more about the art of it, rather than the outcome of it. And what I mean by that is we are so often conditioned that we have to be
我们今天谈论的内容。这是我问每一位嘉宾的问题。所以你显然是在我们的12天嘉宾系列期间来的。这就像是一个机会，可以和12个真正懂这些、超级酷的人交谈。我们的专家有新的视角。你对20多岁的人最大的建议是什么？不必与我们今天讨论的内容相关，有什么是你希望有人曾坐下来对你说的。我对20多岁的人最大的建议是去追求工作，去追求职业，去追求某种更关乎艺术本身、而不是其结果的形式的职业。我的意思是，我们经常被灌输这样的观念：我们必须
immediately successful, we have to make a lot of money right away, we have to have the car, we have to get a nice place, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And I think the most valuable part of our 20s is the capacity to experiment and the capacity to live in a way that I would consider to be frugal. So we can have the freedom to pursue work that is deeply meaningful. I think the biggest mistake that people in their 20s make is they, and this is particularly for Americans, it's not as prevalent in Europe and Australia, but they leave undergrad, they get a job right away and they essentially stay in that job for years and years and years and years. And they end up becoming very miserable. There's no meaning in the work that they do, but they are now tied to it because
立即成功，我们必须马上赚很多钱，我们必须有车，我们必须买个好房子，等等等等。我认为我们20多岁时最宝贵的部分是尝试的能力，以及以我认为是节俭的方式生活的能力。这样我们就能拥有追求意义深远的工作的自由。我认为20多岁的人犯的最大的错误是他们——特别是美国人，这在欧洲和澳大利亚并不那么普遍——他们一毕业就立刻找了一份工作，基本上就在那份工作里待了整整好多年。他们最终变得非常痛苦。他们的工作没有任何意义，但他们现在却被它束缚住了，因为
of the what they called the hedonic treadmill. And I think the greatest opportunity with our 20s is to pursue work that feels artistic, to pursue work that feels like you are creating something, that you are responsible for something and to trust that if you are contributing something of value to those around you, that there will be reciprocity in that and that you will be taken care of. That would be my biggest piece of advice. I love that as well. I found that to be the case for me. So I have to say I 100% agree.
所谓的享乐适应（hedonic treadmill）。我认为在我们20多岁时最大的机会是去追求感觉像艺术的工作，去追求让你觉得自己在创造某些东西、你对某些东西负有责任的工作，并且坚信如果你正在为你周围的人贡献有价值的东西，那么其中就会有回报，你会被照顾好的。这将是我最大的建议。我也很喜欢这个。我发现这对我也适用。所以我必须说我百分之百赞同。
And no one else has said that yet. So everyone's getting something, everyone's getting something unique. Paul, I want to thank you so much for coming on for giving us just so much to think about, giving us so much of the science and much of the research and your opinion as well, your expert opinion. So I really, really appreciate the effort that the work that you're doing, the creative work that you're doing. Where can people find you if they want to learn more? I know you have an amazing book and I was actually reading it. This is so strange, but I was reading some of the reviews and I was like, wow, this looks like a good book.
而且还没有其他人说过这个。所以每个人都能得到一些东西，每个人都能得到独一无二的东西。保罗，非常感谢你能来，为我们提供了这么多引发思考的内容，提供了这么多的科学和研究，以及你的观点，你的专家观点。所以我真的非常非常感谢你所付出的努力，你正在进行的创造性工作。如果人们想了解更多，在哪里可以找到你？我知道你有一本极好的书，我其实正在读它。这太奇怪了，但我当时在看一些书评，然后我想，哇，这看起来是一本好书。
So where can they find more from you? So mastering microdosing is the book. That's on Amazon. You can get it on Kindle. The3rdwave.co. The thirdwave.co. That's our main educational platform. Our training program is there. Our courses are there. I have a podcast that I've hosted for nine years in the psychedelic space. You can check that out there. We have a newsletter. And then I'm on social, mostly on Instagram and Twitter, but also on LinkedIn.
所以他们在哪里可以找到更多你的作品？所以《掌控微剂量》（Mastering Microdosing）就是这本书。那在亚马逊上有售。你可以在Kindle上买到它。the3rdwave.co。the thirdwave.co。那是我们的主要教育平台。我们的培训项目在那里。我们的课程在那里。我在迷幻领域主持了一个播客，我已经主持了九年。你可以在那里查看。我们有一份简报。然后我在社交媒体上，主要在Instagram和Twitter上，也在领英（LinkedIn）上。
If folks are listening to this, add me on LinkedIn. Send me a note. Paul Austin 3W is my social handle. Follow me there. Send me a note. I post almost every day, sometimes fun memes. Usually, like sometimes I'll post long scientific threads on Twitter
如果有人在听这个，在领英上加我。给我发个便条。保罗·奥斯汀3W（Paul Austin 3W）是我的社交账号。在那里关注我。给我发个便条。我几乎每天都发帖，有时是有趣的meme。通常，有时我会在Twitter上发布冗长的科学长文，
about cutting edge research that's been published. So if you're interested in staying up to date on this, the third wave, Paul Austin, and my book mastery in microdosing. Look at that. Perfect. Again,
关于已发表的前沿研究。所以如果你有兴趣了解最新进展，the third wave，保罗·奥斯汀，还有我的书《掌控微剂量》。就是这样。完美。再次，
thank you so much to Paul for coming on. As always, guys, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to give us a follow. We have so many more guest episodes with amazing people coming out. And it's my favorite time of the year to hear from just such wonderful experts. Until next time, stay safe, stay kind. Be gentle to yourself. As always, we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange
非常感谢保罗的到来。和往常一样，伙计们，如果你喜欢这一集，请随意关注我们。我们还有更多邀请出色嘉宾的剧集即将推出。这是我一年中最喜欢的时候，能听到这些精彩专家的分享。直到下次，保持安全，保持善良。对自己温柔一点。和往常一样，我们很快就会再聊。2%. 这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的
modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. Eighty-four is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. Before it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWO.%”。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我和说是一个大时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试着和我们的朋友、喜剧同仁以及最喜欢的作家一起，理解我们是如何熬过那段时光的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代那样。在它成为一个疯狂的年份之前。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is a book. about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听look back at it。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间是一本书。关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何地方都不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做，
listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini.
在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听Learn the hard way。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，欧文斯女士，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大队来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love trapped podcast on the EyeHour Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着剧集的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在EyeHour Heart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听Love Trapped播客。这是一个IHeart播客。人类保证。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。